let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about significant significant figures
sometimes called significant digits and
the idea behind the significant figures
is to just make sure that when you do a
big computation you have a bunch of
digits there that you're not over
representing the amount of precision
that you have that the result isn't more
precise than the things that you
actually measure that you usually use to
get that result but before we go into
the depths of it and how you use it with
computation let's just do a bunch of
examples of identifying significant
figures then we'll try to come up with
some rules of thumb but the general way
to think about it is which digits are
really giving me information about how
precise my measurement is so on this
first thing right over here the
significant figures are this seven zero
zero so over here you have three three
significant significant figures and it
might make you a little uncomfortable
that we're not including these zeros
that are after the decimal point and
before this seven that we're not
including those because just like you
know that helps that does help define
the number and that is true but there's
not it's not telling us how precise our
measurement isn't try to understand this
a little bit better imagine if this
right over here was a measurement of
kilometers so if we measure zero point
zero zero seven zero zero kilometers
that same measurement we could have this
would be the exact same thing as seven
point zero zero meters maybe in fact we
just used a meter stick and we said it's
exactly seven point zero zero meter so
we measured to the nearest centimeter
and we just we just felt like writing it
in kilometers these two numbers are the
exact same thing they're just different
units but I think when you look over
here it makes a lot more sense why you
only have three significant figures
these zeros are just taht kind of
telling you are just are just shifting
it based on maybe what the units of
measurement that you're using but the
numbers that are really giving you the
precision are the seven the zero and the
zero and the reason why we're counting
these trailing zeros is that you didn't
though whoever wrote this number didn't
have to write them down they wrote them
down to explicitly say look I measured
this far if they didn't measure this far
they would have just left these zeros
off and they would have just told you
seven meters
7.00 let's do the next one so based on
the same idea we have the five and the
two the nonzero digits are going to be
significant figures you don't include
this leading zero by the same logic that
if this was point zero five two
kilometers this would be the same thing
as fifty two kilometers which clearly
only has two significant two significant
figures so you don't want to count
leading zeros that are at leading zeroes
before before this before the first non
zero before the nut first non-zero digit
I guess we could say you don't want to
include those you just want to include
all the nonzero digits and everything in
between and and trailing zeros trailing
zeros if a decimal point is involved
I'll make those those ideas a little bit
more formal so over here the person did
370 and then they wrote the decimal
point if they didn't write the decimal
point it would be a little unclear on
how precise this was but because they
wrote the decimal point it means that
they measured it exactly to be 370 they
didn't take get 372 and then round down
or they didn't have kind of a roughness
only to the nearest tens place this
decimal tells you that all three of
these are significant so this is three
significant three significant figures
over here then on this next one
once again this decimal tells us that
not only did we get to the nearest one
but then we put another trailing zero
here which means we got to the nearest
tenth so in this situation once again we
have three significant figures over here
we you know the seven is in the hundreds
but we got all the way down the
measurement went all the way down to the
thousandths place and even though there
are zeroes in between those zeros are
part of our measurement because they are
in between non-zero digits so in this
situation every digit every digit here
the way it's written is a significant
digit so you have six significant digits
now this last one is ambiguous the
37,000 it's not clear whether you
measured exactly 37,000 maybe you
measured to the nearest one and you've
got an exact number you got exactly
37,000 or
maybe you only measured to the nearest
thousand so it depends on what you know
there's there's a little bit of
ambiguity here if you've just see
something written exactly like this you
would probably say if you had to guess
you or not guess if there wasn't any
more information you would say that
there's just two significant digits two
significant figures or significant
digits for this person to be less
ambiguous they would want to put a
decimal point right over there and that
lets you know that there was that this
is actually five digits of precision
that we actually go to five significant
figures so if you don't see that decimal
point I would go with two